votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 follower sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirer
talents.com
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir leng et
calais
[Applaudissements]
et philippe il va avoir sur l'adversaire
tout de suite je sais ça sert toujours
la même on a versé avant le combat
c'est tous les matins comme ça aux
ciseaux ce top chef ces normes sont
arrivés le matin elle est géniale
toi tu es comme ça un petit peu hattab
régime entend dans une auto croissant
ils arrivent ils marchent ils voient
prendre pendant te dis oh [ __ ] j'ai
fait une connerie je lui dis un truc et
il serre la main de fer il faut quand
même dire par là c'est qu'on prend un
bon temps donc il ya toujours pas
d'aller vite on est d'accord avec à
paços le bras de fer entre philippe et y
rester aux caps comeau car il prend ça
très au sérieux c'est hyper je pense que
il va il va très mal le vide mais
philippe vous donnerai tout bien sûr ça
s'appelle le quiz cuisine quiz
j'ai passé tout le week end à kloten
jingle
alors hélène vous vous êtes avec tous
les chroniqueurs vous faites partie de
leur équipe ou pouvait les aider et led
vous philippe et stéphane vous êtes avec
valérie bénaïm vous êtes avec jean
michel maire et thierry moreau autant
vous dire que vous avez de la chance
mais non je vais vous poser des
questions sur la cuisine c'est très
simple jouer en équipe
d'accord avec vous si vous répondez bien
c'est l'autre équipe qui va soulever la
cloche chez qui va manger un des membres
va manger ce qu'il ya en dessous la
cloche alors philippe etchebest on l
aime parce que il est comme ça moi
j'aime bien les gars comme ça tu vois
ils disent qu'ils pensent voilà s'il
avait un truc à te dire à gilles verdez
il l'a dit il a un truc à dire à mokhtar
et la coursive
alors
à ce bras de fer vous l'attendez
alalalala regarder qui va gagner à ckoi
préféré philippe n'est pas fou moi
j'aime tout j'aimais tout et vous montre
tard c'est quoi votre plat préféré
naldo bien la loubia merci voilà pour
tous les tunisiens qui nous regardent
alors c'est quoi votre meilleur bras en
fait j'ai les deux bras péter non à
rennes après de biceps rupture des
biceps des deux bras gauche et droite
ont déjà la moitié non non moi mais
c'est pas grave mais votre meilleur bras
le droit
vous êtes bien là alors d'accord je suis
là il écoute attention
allez-y les chéris bien sûr vous
connaissez les règles ou double bien
entendu on va alors attention vous êtes
prêt d'égérie attention top à 2,3 aparté
ah ouais quand même
ah ouais
tu vas te réveiller afin de faire rôle
devant toute la france
c'est quoi ces cas là c'est un plat
japonais
je sais pas du tout ce que c'est et
c'est quoi je suis c'est la base de
fromage les couacs horrible ça sent fort
c'est quoi c'est quoi fanfaronner matos
et quads et motos
c'est à base de fromage de 2 petits pois
ces japonais y dénoncer ce jeudi les
jeunes est très populaire et qui va
manger pour vos images allez-y alors qui
vous connaît une bonne cuillère ce sera
sénat bouffer à oui il ya quoi dedans
des incidents et du fromage c'est
horrible alors c'est des haricots de
soja fermenté pas très bon mais abbas ça
parce que les forces les mauves ont
commencé la salir et salir ce taux
rester comme ça long débat est légal le
bras de fer
il a aussi moins que l'émission top chef
oui
[Applaudissements]
il sait bien
voici la question quelle place est très
apprécié en namibie pour y jouer avec
nous le museau d'antilopes l'anus de
phacochères griller les cuisses de
chauves-souris de chauves-souris ou une
bonne choucroute alsacienne
alors on a mis ce qu'est votre
représentant s'est félicité pris une
tôle aux bottes on va faire maintenant
le prendre alors oui les chauves-souris
clef chauffée michel sachez que ça n'est
pas la bonne soupe cotisation ça n'est
pas le museau d'antilopes est ce qui
fait un carton en namibie et j'en ai
mangé jeu j'adore ça c'est l'anus de
fako mais non je vous jure que c'est la
liste de phacochères est un mets très
raffiné en namibie
il se déguste souvent crié au coin du
feu lors d'un dîner romantique c'est à
dire quand vous avez un dîner romantique
auditoire oui bah voilà oui ça c'est du
passé c'est mon ex sont plus là vous
voyez aller et macao macarons gingembre
et faites vous plaisir car jean-louis
cottigny tuer on a mangé entier alors
attention là là je vais vous dire c'est
sur cette question qu'à sion on y va
alors attention qu elles vivent quels
animaux c'est la question bonus est en
train de crever à gauche mais attention
quels aliments lequel de ces aliments
contient le plus de faire je l'ait pas
attendre on parle là non
alors je n'ai pas les cherry on the
bible parle et parle d'une question que
je n'ai pas merci les chéris ont fait la
question bonus yoplait question vous
monsieur mambé on n'apprend jamais on a
baissé à la 24 n'est pas bon